but uh i guess like so you don't do
hosting anymore right like you yeah i
don't belong to a club anymore you know
wait what does that mean
so
this is like a deposition it's like
you're not answering the question by
answering the question you can take
you can take the man
how the [ __ ] you freelance host so you
know previous clients since i've been
doing this for almost an hour right now
yeah like the people have
you know
met along the way
at this point they're just there to you
know drink with me to get live updates
because i'm known as an old friend yeah
i've known there for like almost 10
years some of them you know all right
that's great that means you guys are
being invited to weddings and [ __ ] you
know of the girls that are getting
married you know like and i went to some
why should not what
people at the wedding how did that go
were they like oh this is jen this is
the guy oh yeah yeah
wait how did the wife explain to the
husband that's what i was gonna ask so
for example like there was a lady who
was
back in the day she was in her late
university time yeah and i was telling
her you know like you should do exchange
go to other countries
live life giving life advice yeah
exactly and then a few years later you
know i find out that she's marrying
somebody she met overseas master her
experience abroad and then she says she
got to do this just because i [ __ ]
gave her the encouragement to go abroad
right i'm skipping like the whole arc
here but i i caught that that's the end
result here i imagine the husband was
like you're inviting what a host
this is my ncr
husband meets me and then i talk about
you know the way we met and you're
hustling what kind of
quality conversations we have nobody's
like you know like suspecting anything
you know yeah because i'm like i'm
honest but did you tell them that you
were tell him that you were a host dude
that's how the wife introduced
like you know i'm saying that's it the
wife's got some balls
like i've never seen someone with such
like big dick energy yeah hi honey hi
honey he's hi honey here's another man
that i spent a lot of money on uh before
i met you
but we met because of this man dude
like interestingly i have a lot of that
you know even with my ex-girlfriends i
still see some of them japan is whack
with their parents
and we still hang out and [ __ ] yeah and
that's still the case with hostel stuff
like some people that don't even see me
anymore just want to hang out with their
new boyfriends
yeah what melee and see what you're
writing yeah uh
yeah dude
we can't say that out well i'm gonna ask
that yeah we let off settle can you just
say yes or no to me i mean you can't
hint at it
[Music]
the wedding isn't as innocent as it
seems to say that i mean you know
everyone you know the hosts are not just
for talking right but you can't say that
i don't know i know i know i know
brought your sentence
what what are what are part of the hosts
responsibilities it's not all disneyland
that's what i'm saying
it's not all this
are there more perks to the job uh
that's uh other than just that
so we both get perks yeah
to answer your question kind of directly
but indirectly
it involves a lot of mental
psychological you know like [ __ ]
meaning
if you know what somebody wants and you
give it to them straight away you might
get them
to be bored of you and then they might
not come back for more
okay so the strategy for some cases is
to tease and edge
but
what are you laughing at man what are
you laughing at it's like [ __ ] bonnie
stinson from how i met your mother it's
like
it's insane
i understand that it's the job right
yeah
it's one side of it though one side of
it on the other side there are some
people that don't want you for what
you're you know no i understand that
like they just did your conversation
exactly they're therefore just for your
company and so if you push right on a
drunken evening you might just [ __ ]
ruin your relationship and then they
might not come back
so there's a lot that you have to think
about and this is with any other social
encounter you know if you think somebody
is beautiful and they're wonderful and
you feel like you want to spend the
night with them
and they're down for it as well
and it's yeah yeah i was gonna say
because you know obviously obviously
it's the only thing that they they pay
for is the drinks
yeah
all they pay for is the drakes but what
you're trying to do is secure that they
keep coming for those strengths exactly
yeah you know you do what you got to do
i understand that business is business
and it's ruthless you know and it's it's
childish or naive to think that that
it's not how the business works right
right i've said that it doesn't mean i
can't be like that's [ __ ] up
just to make myself clear the way i
conduct myself is with my wits and
intelligence and yeah unique ability of
talking about [ __ ] that they have no
idea about which is right you are you
are a worldly host yeah exactly miss
award white [ __ ] people right yeah
yeah
that's how i you know do my thing
but there are some people that of course
push their you know physical attributes
and they fall into dilemma where you
know
if i don't give it to her now
she might not come back next time but if
i give it to her now
she definitely won't come back you know
exactly right right you know if you're
like this and you suck at it
it's gonna happen no i i totally get it
you know that's that's just the
environment and the industry of the host
club yeah but you know i'm sure to a lot
of people watching and you know some
people who are not versed in this
world it seems otherworldly it is almost
like for them it's like what sex what's
to be fair i think i think one not even
lie one of the most underrated like
uh different aspects of japanese culture
is the nightlife and the the whole the
you know the host industry and all that
like i think it's
people are like oh it's so wacky they
have kfc on christmas it's like
the real weird differences between the
west is the [ __ ] that don't get doesn't
get talked about stuff that's
completely different and you know in
some ways i you know i as a you come
into this with a farm perspective and
you judge it as such but i feel like in
some ways it's unfair of us to judge and
be like that's that's [ __ ] weird what
they do it's like well i mean that's
what they do that's that's what they've
chosen to do and that's how they do the
business is it does it sound predatory
at times a little bit but i mean you
know it's my perspective you know yeah i
mean and you know again like as you were
saying like it is a thing that i think
again japan is so good at maintaining a
culture yeah right and like maintaining
ways to do a culture where sometimes
ancient artists yeah yeah
yeah where sometimes you know
they get so they get so encapsulated in
holding on to this specific cultural
thing yeah that they almost failed to
realize that you know what maybe it
doesn't really fit into society today's
standards right like that's the whole
reason why the [ __ ] faction machine
still exists right
it's like you know maybe great point
right maybe it's like you know like they
don't realize that you know they just
think themselves yeah it's [ __ ] up but
this is how it came to be this this is
what makes japanese life japanese
nightlife they never stop to think to
themselves
hey maybe this is [ __ ] up yeah just a
bit